whatever is going on with Conor McGregor
it does not appear that he's going to be
fighting anytime soon I remember where I
was when I got the news it was going to
be Chandler versus McGregor it didn't
feel right from Jump Street then they
got Dana Chandler and Connor and three
different people interviewed them
Chandler says we're doing it 55.
McGregor says we're doing it at 70 and
Dana says we haven't found a weight
class yet if you don't even know what
weight class you're doing it at there is
no fight Conor McGregor now according to
Social Media which I get that he's a
troll but most recently says we're gonna
do it at 185. and Chandler instantly
responds and goes great let's do it it's
like Mike at some point you don't have
to look so Willy and at some point
somebody here is going to have to play
hardball or nothing if nothing changes
then the outcome doesn't change and the
outcome right now is you guys aren't
fighting you know it's like when you're
chasing the hot girl the more desperate
you are the more they're like nah I'm
good man you know so I think Chandler
needs to play a little hard to get and
go you know I'm gonna move on UFC give
me another fight and see how Connor
reacts be the hot girl in school